most people don't use their imagination
constructively most people use their
imagination destructively they imagine
what they don't want overcoming fear is
one of the greatest moves a person can
make do you tell yourself a lie often
enough you're gonna start to believe it
wanna be happy
build a life not just the business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn six pieces of
life-changing advice from Bob Procter
the joy okay let's kick it off with
advice number one start with a vision
most people don't use their imagination
constructively most people use their
imagination destructively they imagine
what they don't want we've got to
consciously and deliberately imagine
what we do want if we will take and sit
down with a pen and ask yourself what do
I really want what do I really want and
write it down and then make a written
description of it in the present tense
writing causes thinking thinking creates
an image and you get these images going
you're building a vision in your mind
it's the visionaries that's changed the
world think of that the fact that I can
sit and look into this camera and you
can sit and look at me on your phone or
on your TV or on your laptop that was
the result of somebody's vision
generally everything you've got the
clothes you wear the house you live in
this microphone that's in front of me it
was all the result of somebody's vision
it's not an accident you and I have a
marvelous imagination
and everything starts with a vision van
Gogh is asked how he did such beautiful
work he said first I dream my painting
and then I paint my dream what do you
want to do in your life where do you
want to go what do you want to make
happen what do you want to make happen
for between now in the end of the year
think about it for a moment don't think
of why you can't don't matter how much
money you've got doesn't matter how much
help you've got build a vision of what
you would I like to accomplish between
now and the end of the year and then
make a written description of that
vision
paint the picture with words you rather
way with this you can start write the
picture and it'll come on the screen in
your mind or build the picture and then
paint it with words vision vision is
going to direct your life if you let it
advice number to overcome fear
overcoming fear is one of the greatest
moves a person can make first of all we
have to ask yourself what causes fear
fears caused by ignorance not knowing
and if we're gonna go and do anything
new if we're gonna break out of a
paradigm if we're gonna change habit
patterns we're wandering into an area
we've never been and you know fear stops
most people you'll find people afraid to
talk to a stranger
you'll find individuals afraid to stand
up and ask the question in front of
other people you'll find salespeople
afraid to make a sales call afraid to
ask for the order stop and think of how
confining that is a person is putting
themself into a small cell but it's in
their own mind the doors aren't locked
they can open and you can walk away to
free them if you learn to overcome fear
when you face fear it leaves you face
the thing you fear and it'll leave you
that's really the secret of it in fact
if you hold yourself back because of
fear your life actually comes to a stop
because nothing gets better than it is
you've got to be courageous now great
just people aren't without fear
courageous people are the ones that face
their fear I think Eddie Rickenbacker
pointed that out the great pilot don't
let fear stop you make up your mind
you're gonna step out and do it stop and
think of the number of people that are
in jobs that they don't like and they're
afraid to leave or people in
relationships that are destructive and
they're afraid to leave this is a
terrible way to live and it's not
necessary it's just caused by ignorance
and when we step out and do something we
gain in their awareness we develop an
understanding and like that the fear is
gone
make up your mind that fear it's not
going to stop you from doing the thing
you really want to do step out and do it
today advice number three believe you
tell yourself a lie often enough you're
gonna start to believe it and way around
1900 William James said believe and your
belief will create the fact it's got to
be believed you've got to believe it and
if there's no belief it ain't going to
happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea and
that makes all kinds of things happen
when you believe it there's no quitting
you never quit it doesn't matter what
happens you don't quit quitting is never
an option I the people that quit they
never really bought into the idea in the
first place see you've got it you you
get it on three levels the second you
think of something you've got it
intellectually when you get emotionally
involved you've got it on a spiritual or
emotional level well then that expresses
itself through the body but it's just an
instrument of your mind
and so when you're really buying into it
you literally fuse with it Neville said
you fuse with it and this causes all
kinds of things to happen you're dealing
with electronics you're dealing with
energy like the second you think
something
that's all you need see you live on
frequencies you think on frequencies
your phone operates on frequencies and
it's like magic and you're you're in
Romania is right I'm in Toronto yes if
I've got your number on my phone I could
take a picture something hit it like
that you've got it in Romania
simultaneous with me sending it because
when you get into the mind there isn't
any time or space it's just immediate
yeah well though you're living on
frequencies now when you think of
something what you've done is you
flipped your brain onto a higher
frequency
the very fact you can see it is all the
proof you need to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency and
then you will attract whatever on that
frequency all the good you need to
manifest the idea also if you want more
confident self love and motivation check
out my 254 series they're free the links
to join are in the description below I
was reminded this morning of a question
I'm often asked how do you eliminate
fear from your life so I started to
study myself I found most people don't
know who they are they really don't all
things are possible if you believe
advice number four don't waste your
minutes any times if you had somebody
say to you or have you got a minute Bob
we got a minute in one minute would you
think about that I read a poem one time
I said I have only just a minute only 60
seconds and it was forced upon me I
can't refuse that I didn't seek it and I
didn't choose it but it's up to me to
use it I must suffer if I lose it give a
count if I abuse it it's only a tiny
little minute but eternity is in it well
in any rate I thought I'm gonna put this
on a video and I'm just gonna share it
with everybody just this one little part
out of the seminar I'm making I want you
to look at this Sam timer and let this I
want you to think about your life the
sand in the top of the glass represents
the future the sand and the bottom of
the glass represents the past now Genoa
we know what's in the past and young we
can't do anything about it you know
guess you don't know how much sands in
the top of the glass you may think you
have a lot you might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little that you might have a lot when I
was a little boy I was raised by my
grandmother and I don't know when I was
Lily after she was probably sixty but as
long as I can remember gran would say
I'll soon begun there I'll soon be gone
well you know we loved her she was
really an angel of God but we thought
you was never gonna go she lived to be
94 for 30-some years I'll soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left now about the same
time I had a buddy of mine Bob Yates he
was just 16 and bang he run into the
abutment of a bridge and his life was
snuffed out if you had asked him a half
hour before how much sand he had left he
would have said at least a half a
century he didn't have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left the future we don't
know the past it's gone now the only
thing you can deal with is what's right
here right now and if you look the sand
is always moving now think of this you
see I was working on that and then I was
working on a graph I've got here at my
computer and I'm thinking at the time
somebody said - have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute do
you know if you're running fifty
thousand dollars a year a minutes 42
cents a half-hour is $12.50 if we take
that ahead of it if you're earning
$80,000 a year a minute 67 cents half
hours $20 turning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute and
then it cost you a dollar twenty-five a
minute and a half hours thirty seven
dollars and fifty cents so do you see if
somebody said you want to stop for a cup
of coffee well if you're earning a
quarter of a million dollars a year a
minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hour $62.50 and then of course
you've got the coffee to pay for on top
of that so do you see the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now and I have found the people that
win are the people who make up their
mind then I'm gonna waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
gonna make it happen
every minute advice number five
absolutely love what you do love is the
greatest thing love what you do I went
to visit her all night yell one time way
back in the 60s I'll never forget it and
I was leaving I felt I was so grateful I
had an hour of his time
and I said Earl what's real secret I
mean what's the big deal
well I said there is a big deal about
there isn't any secret it's simply a
matter of sitting down and determining
what you really love to do and then make
a decision to dedicate your life to it
man did I get excited he said the
problem is most people is they don't
know what to do and they never make a
decision to dedicate their life to
anything I could suggest I knew exactly
what i would love doing I would love to
do what he was doing that made up my
mind I want to do it and I want to do it
with him and I made up my mind I would
make a commitment to that for the rest
of my life you know something that's
exactly what I've done I love what I'm
doing I love it I absolutely love it now
when you love doing something you'll run
baby and you won't get weary you're
walking you won't get tired you know why
you're a free flow the energies are
freely flowing through you you are
greatest instrument then that God's got
you're here to do God's work what's
God's Word God's work his creation God's
the creator you're creating God's image
you even give them creative faculties
fall in love with what you do and you'll
be creating great stuff wherever you go
love what you do love the people that
you're working with fall in love with
the idea of love and advice number six
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is study yourself I met a man here
in Toronto he was one that originally
got me involved in study in this race to
an furred and he told me if I didn't
like the results I was getting in my
life that I was going to have to change
me because there were my
results and he said if you're going to
change you you're gonna have to find out
something about yourself and that seemed
to make sense I don't think it was an
earth-shattering idea I wouldn't give
anybody a brain hernia but it made a lot
of sense to me so I started to study
myself I found most people don't know
who they are they really don't what do
you mean I mean I know my name I know my
age and that's not you know that's the
average person who they are they'll give
you their name they'll say I'm Bob
Proctor but I'm not Bob and Proctor two
words my parents give them to me they're
called names but it's not me it's my
name then some people say well this is
me but this isn't me either it's my body
like you never phone down here to the to
the studio and say body won't the end
today it's sick okay you know we don't
say em handrim leg it's my hand my leg
my body my name room.i well that's an
interesting question and I believe if a
person will start to study that and look
for the answer they'll find it see I
think we live simultaneously on three
planes of understanding for spiritual
creatures we have an intellect and we
live in physical bodies okay because we
lack awareness or understanding of who
we are we're totally locked into a
physical world and we let things outside
of us control us 95% of the population
are reacting to life they're not really
living at all now got a special bonus
tip from Bob on how to move into action
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to stop wasting your
minutes number two what's the fear that
you need to overcome and number three
how will you believe in yourself more
and if you made it this far in the video
you're still watching and you commit to
taking action after watching this video
I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believed on the video as well
Don Shula they coach of the old my Miami
Dolphins he said it's the start that
stops most people and he's right it is
the start to stops those people they're
always gonna get ready to get set to get
going
what we've got to do is boom just like
that move into action see if you don't
get started you're never gonna get
finished how do we do that start early
I believe when you wake up you should
get up the second you wake up get your
feet hit the floor move into action and
you know you'd be wise if you sit down
at night before you go to bed and write
down six goal achieving activities
now that doesn't go to the store go to
the bank or get to cleaning it's not
that these are goal achieving activities
write down six of them and when you wake
up in the morning you move into action
you know where you're gonna go you don't
even have to think about it step in
actually get on the first one when you
get it done forget it and go to the
second one don't think about the first
one focus on two don't even think about
three when you get to then go to three
but not come off one at a time if you
don't get them all done just move them
over on to the next day and that doesn't
mean if you only get three done that you
have nine the next day there are three
of the six that you're gonna do the next
day six goal achieving activities and
when you wake up in the morning move
into action on them
quit hold yourself back don't wait and
say well I really don't know how I'm
going to get started and the way will
show itself it just appears I have found
when you get started when you move into
action everything starts to happen
around you
if you want to learn how to attract
success into your life with Bob Proctor
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I want to explain something to you that
not many people really understand I want
to talk about the law of attraction